[Applause]
[Music]
19:45 battleship Missouri 53,000 ton
flagship of Admiral Halsey's 3rd fleet
becomes the scene of an unforgettable
ceremony marking the complete and formal
surrender of Japan folks on August 15th
1945 having suffered the only nuclear
bomb attack in history only a few days
previously for Japanese government's
finally surrendered the Allied powers I
announce it my firm purpose in the
tradition of the countries I represent
to proceed in the discharge of my
responsibilities for justice and
tolerance while taking all necessary
dispositions to ensure that the terms of
surrender are pull a prompt way and
faithfully complied with
[Music]
at that moment Japan was a defeated
country its economy was shattered and
the Japanese that suffered unimaginable
damage not only were they immersed in
extreme poverty that also lost more than
3 million compatriots brothers sons even
mothers war it takes a terrible toll
with this grim picture is the situation
in 1945 the question that we might ask
ourselves is well how did Japan manage
to become one of the greatest economic
powers on the planet in such a short
amount of time and how did the Japanese
recover so quickly with such might it's
a son
[Applause]
[Music]
dear viewer here on visual politic we've
already talked about the differences
between the German model and the
Japanese model we've also told you about
how Japan transformed from a medieval
country to a thriving modern nation
however we still need to answer the
question of how Japan managed to become
a great world power in just a few years
let me tell you right now for the
japanese model is rather peculiar so
we're going to need more than one video
to explain it here in this video we're
gonna see a few brushstrokes in the
whole picture but don't worry more
chapters are absolutely going to follow
the post-war in 1945 it seemed like
everything that had been built after the
Meiji Restoration of 1868 simply
evaporated moreover as if that weren't
enough for the first time in its history
Japan was occupied by the United States
but hold on for just a second because it
wasn't all bad news as we'll see the
Japanese also had three aces up their
sleeves three characteristics that would
launch their country into the
stratosphere turning it into one of the
richest countries on the planet and
that's all in spite of the many
political mistakes that both the
occupation forces and the local
authorities would make over the coming
years
[Music]
[Applause]
so you want to know what the three
ingredients were the main ingredients of
this Japanese success recipe well first
of all a huge ability and predilection
for saving you see in Asian countries in
general and Japan is no exception
families try to save every penny much
more so than almost any other place on
earth
why well there aren't many explanations
for this phenomena cultural preference a
trend towards less consumption in the
present in order to spend more in the
future or just because of a lack of
public services which tend to be very
limited in this part of the world all of
these explanations may have a bit of
truth to them but regardless these huge
amounts of savings are then invested
which creates productive capital that
obviously leads to higher production and
wealth levels its savings that allow us
to direct our efforts for a long time
not to satisfy our immediate needs but
to worry about satisfying our future
needs we produce capital goods so that
they in turn manufacture the future
consumer goods we may need want ramond
Rio alright so the first days that Japan
had up its leave after the war was an
enormous propensity to save savings
savings and just more savings the
seconds it had a lot to do with a Meiji
Restoration of 1868
you see as we saw in a previous video
one of the first things the Japanese
government did after the regime change
was bet on creating a very powerful
educational system
they established universal primary
education and promoted universities
academies research centers etc thus
after the Second World War
despite their situation the Japanese
were the most well trained workers on
the entire Asian continent and of course
this entails a huge competitive
advantage
[Applause]
but also one of the first measures taken
after the war was pushing the
educational system even further and so
what's the third card well is the one
you can probably guess and that's the
Japanese is huge capacity and
willingness for working long hours and
in some cases they've even taken things
right to the extreme I mean do you know
any other country in the world that has
a word for death from working too much
Karoshi death from working too much is a
public health problem in Japan the fact
is that all three of these factors they
gave Japan a huge capacity to recover
grow and create a great deal of wealth
but hold on a second because well having
seen all of this what exactly are the
stages that Japan goes through in order
for this economic miracle to happen well
listen up the stages
[Music]
the process we're about to explore
starts with the us's occupation of Japan
after the end of the war see the
occupation forces had two major
priorities to demilitarize and
democratize Japan it's around this time
for example that the new constitution
establishing a democratic system was
created it equalized men's and women's
rights and it stripped Japan of its
right to wage war dismantling its Armed
Forces in addition the occupation forces
copied u.s. institutions and launched
reforms that had some benefits and many
drawbacks I think one day we're gonna
need to talk about how badly the
military has always managed the economy
of countries they've controlled but
that's something we'll deal with in a
future video the fact is that the
priority of these reforms was to
eliminate or at least to reduce the
power of the oligarchs who supported
Japanese expansionism and militarism to
do so the sale of lands from big
landowners to small farmers it was
approved measures were taken to dissolve
these I'm bad soo large business groups
that engaged in many activities that
were controlled by a single family an
antitrust law that outlawed monopolies
was also passed in 1947 and the
unionization of workers was also
promoted everything was done with the
intention of achieving and economic
power change
of course some of these measures in
addition to blimmin the power of the
great oligarchs also had some rather
positive consequences for example the
land distribution managed to turn many
farmers into owners need to Mai's of
many of these I had soup led to the
emergence of many small and medium-sized
enterprises in spite of everything the
recovery
it was much slower than expected however
in the 1950s the country hands as it
were a stroke of luck the Korean War
turned Japan into one of the Alliance
forces suppliers thereby boosting their
exports and their production suddenly
Japanese companies and politicians they
discovered the great global market in
1953 production levels that already
surpassed the levels that been right
before the Warrens the political class
had a new priority boosting economic
growth through business the economic
takeoff
[Music]
folks the decades of the 50s 60s and 70s
were miraculous years they were Japan's
Golden Age it was a time led by the
Liberal Democratic Party a political
party that ruled the country for almost
40 uninterrupted years a few years ago
by the way it was discovered that the
CIA actually gave a lot of money to
support the party's political campaigns
this is also the party of the current
prime minister Shinzo Abe a the fact is
that this party launched a very peculiar
system see on the one hand it promoted
policies that favored saving keeping
inflation under control and slowing down
the growth of the public sector as well
as maintaining low taxes and avoiding
the accumulation of debt this is the
opposite of what they do in countries
like Argentina or icily for example
however hold on just a second because
that's not all now on the other hand
unlike what happens in other countries
that achieved great economic takeoff the
truth is that these government's they
were quite interventionalist for example
they've decided to promote certain
industries which they themselves chosen
to which they helped grow from within
the government itself they also promoted
a new cart Alizee ssin of national
companies supposedly to avoid what they
considered to be excessive competition
although you know I don't really know
here but that just sure sounds like a
way for them to help out their friends
regardless it did have amazing results
in the early 1960s Prime Minister
Hayatou Ikeda announced a plan to double
the size of Japan's economy in just 10
years to reach this goal the country
needed to maintain an annual average
growth rate of 7.2% for that entire time
international analysts considered it
impossible ten years later Japan had far
exceeded its goal the country had
multiplied the size of its economy by
2.8 because it had an average annual
growth rate of more than 9.3 percent
[Music]
thus in 1973 the Japanese economy had
multiplied more than five since 1953
that is in just 20 years on the other
hand GDP per capita multiplied by four
and within a few years Japan became the
largest asset holder in the world and
the largest humanitarian aid provider
even the Tokyo Stock Exchange managed to
outperform the New York Stock Exchange
for a short period of time but you know
what this is when a great controversy
arose on one side some defended the
country's spectacular growth despite all
of these government policies that is to
say that the three things we covered at
the beginning of this video savings work
and training were so strong that they
managed to take off in spite of the
government's interference but some argue
that since the government kept the
macroeconomic parameters under control
of these public policies actually
accelerated the country's growth
now the only question is which one do
you think is right which group do you
belong to well leave your answer in the
comments section below and also in this
survey what there's little doubt about
though is that it was exactly during
that time that some of the greatest
imbalances that led the country into a
huge crisis from which it hasn't yet
recovered emerged but we already talked
about that in this previous other video
so well I really hope you enjoyed this
video please do hit that like button if
you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos also don't forget
to check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine
also this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always I'll see you in the next video